it's really how can we make technology
as symbiotic to the human experience as
possible right where I don't have to
actually even look at a thing I don't
have to go look for my phone or look for
my iPad right I can access the data as
soon as I think it right that's where
it's going is like as soon as I think
about something I should be able to have
instant hands-free access to that data
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Saucon we're on-site
at the transformative technology
conference for our second partnership
with them we are now gonna be talking
about the next o s we have Andres force
on joining us on the show hi Andreas hey
Allen thanks for having me I'm so pumped
for this I'm happy to be here yeah I
mean just being at your office in Santa
Barbara just last month and you showing
me your tech demo of the next OS and I
was like this is what's up and now we're
here we all get to do the show finally
I'm excited I'm so happy to be here and
you do you meet some amazing people so
I'm I'm glad to be here and helping to
spread the educational word around what
we're trying to do and what's what's a
hell yeah yeah exactly and I'm so pumped
to dive into that with Andres in a
little bit
we love starting things off with asking
you some questions about the nature of
this reality first one is are we really
all one yeah oh man that's a that's a
great question are we one in my mind
we're essentially electric beings right
we're we're we're essentially energy and
essentially energy that is separating
mass and other elements and you know I
think truthfully yeah we are all one I'm
we're a composition of molecules and
energy and we sort of assembled our
physiological bodies to carry our energy
you know I was just having a
conversation downstairs earlier today
with somebody and the question was
around when you when you have you ever
encountered someone where you felt like
you knew them forever like the first
time and we there were a number of
people I met today where I had that kind
of moment where it really felt like
we've known each other forever like and
had never met before and I think there's
something there that's hard to explain
yeah yeah and then the next question
that I like asking after this is do you
have feelings of deep profound
interconnectedness or egodeath or
unconditional love or hyper
present-moment or like tell us about
these experiences maybe that you've had
I've had them but they come in moments
right you have this sort of phase
shifting that happens where you really
collapse into yourself right and then
there's other times where you feel
completely dematerialized and you feel
like you're intertwined with the ones
around you you know and I think it's
it's an interesting state of how you
break that down and and how you can try
and make sense of it I think a lot of it
has to do with my experience of feeling
sort of a oneness is in communication
right so it's not just sitting next to
someone and being proximate to their
bodies and having physical proximity to
each other but actually in the
communication not even the shared
language right but it's my ability to or
your ability to move molecules from your
body in such a way that I I feel
welcomed I feel a part of your energy
right and and so I encounter a number of
people who they they speak in a very one
directional way
and it's very rough right it's a rough
slap shop way of communication and you
don't feel so much like a oneness in
that communication but then if you're
communicating or you're being
communicated to with a caring sense a
sense of care and a sense of receipt
like how do you receive receive my
communication those who can deliver
communication in a way that has the
other feel like they're being thoughtful
you know you're thinking through the
reception of it I think that's where you
really have these bonds and so the I
think communication and thinking about
how we operate as humans and how
technology might be able to help us
connect at a much more visceral level
even if you don't speak the same
language yes I love this it takes us up
to like a macro view of literally the
words that you say right now are
directly making an imprint in my
physiology period there's just no way
around it I'm becoming changed every
moment that I listen to your words and
so there is a very serious
interconnected relationship between us
and there's a very serious
interconnected relationship between the
air that you're breathing the water
you're drinking the food that you're
eating between the Sun giving that
energy in between phytoplankton and
trees giving you the air that you're
living in you know I mean just endless
the amount of interconnectedness
but we need to augment our perception to
see that interconnect is me to train our
faculties of awareness to see and feel
the deep embodied states of those and
not just like the intellectual
masturbated versions but the actual felt
experiences of those and then if you can
do something even deeper like try and do
something like fMRI or EEG or EKG or
just some sort of a biometric analysis
of what's going on during those
interconnected states that you can prove
potentially when people are actually in
those states not you can get
billionaires and government leaders and
corporate leaders and even grassroots
people to beat
stood on that kind of stuff yeah yeah
well yeah and thinking about how people
are radiating right how they're
radiating their energy or how they're
expressing well I used the words just
expression right so you can express
yourself in words you can express
yourself with dance with movement with
just simply your the emptiness or the
pause right so the uncomfortable pause
in speech you can have the pause and
body movement and presence and the
ability to be aware of how you are in
such a way to create a dynamic right and
so like you're saying like these things
come they have a lot to do with
self-reflection and understanding
oneself and also observing others and
learning and constantly learning from
other people but what's also interesting
and because we're a trans tech
conference understanding the science
right there's the human there's the
science around the human which is what
99% of what is going on here is around
understanding the science of humanity
and how transformative technology can be
for Humanity but you were talking about
you know the ability to sense things
right that are beyond our own
explanation and and and you know you
look at things like bats or you look at
fish in dolphins and animals and other
kinds of mammals and creatures and and
they all have their own kinds of senses
right and and so the ability to
understand that for instance our eyes
are constrained like we have an immense
amount of data coming through as input
through our eyes your eyes are seeing
for what's most salient for what's most
salient but there's a there's an entire
band of light that we can't even see
right with our own eyes now you can
augment our eyes to enhance the sexual
range and depth of things which is a way
of augmenting things of color it's like
a snake see infrared like bats use
ultrasound yeah use well dolphins
they're like echolocation locations like
this
you have birds use like there's a
there's folks that are using
magnetometers for defining true north
and doing body hacking like install AZ
optic sensors on my body so that you
know I could at any given time know its
direction yeah like the vibration kind
of goes a little faster a little slower
and you know when you first experience
it it feels awkward right but then all
of a sudden the plasticity your mind
your mind starts to just forget that
that enhancement is there and your brain
remap yes and it just becomes a extra
sense and so there's a lot of brain
adapts just like that the brain is
extremely pliable yeah right it's
extremely plastic in the sense of we as
humans don't you know as adults I should
say children are always sensing right
there do this putting their hands in
their mouths and touching things and
smelling things and really embracing the
full sensual discovery process that
discovery journey that journey of
understanding what you can sense and so
on but then as adults we stop really
exploring the possibilities beyond
what's right in our face right and and
and so what we're really looking at and
we the this community and people like
yourself and myself are really looking
at how can we truly enhance the human
experience in such a way that isn't just
to do it like we're not just trying to
enhance the human experience we're
trying to enhance it in a way that
brings a whole nother level of
capability to the human performance
right and how do you you know how do you
look at individuals that might be
neurotypical you know or average or even
high performers and how do you enhance
say take someone from good to great
there's a lot of work being done in
those areas for you know biohacking
neural hacking all kinds of things about
getting increased performance
quantitative self all this stuff is all
around augmentation you're augmenting
your diet you're augmenting the you know
the oxygen you breathe you're augmenting
the water you're taking into your system
your your
you know everything your vascular system
is getting augmented and we're doing it
through nutrition or through high-tech
or low-tech solutions right and so
there's a lot of work going on there but
then there's also the other end of the
spectrum so if you look at it from a
there's a zero point and you're going
from you know sort of a deficit or a
positive a lot of us are sort of on the
positive side we're sort of taking a
positive and making it even more
positive but there's a number of folks
who have certain physical disabilities
that it's all about restoration right so
not to sort of steal the company's name
Restoration Hardware but it's kind of
like a lot of what we're doing is like
how do we hack and develop sensitive you
know sensory solutions that can augment
individuals bodies and physical
augmentation as well as cognitive
augmentation to restore capabilities or
perhaps even create an extra sense or an
extra capability that was never there
before yes damn you have that entire
sense explosion is so fascinating yeah
you can gain back the sense that may not
have developed or you may endeavor into
brand new senses and just train that
plasticity of the brain to adapt to that
there's an tremendous amount of advance
what's that are happening here with
brain computer interface and I'm like
the reality that we're all that we're
gonna dive into and talk about I really
really really want to hear your thoughts
on this like as we dive into the next OS
I want to hear your thoughts on this
because we're talking about it from such
an interconnected perspective that
everything is so interconnected could it
be that all of the downstream issues
that we have in our world are due to the
upstream issue of us feeling the
illusion of separation hmm I I do see
it's it's it's kind of funny there's
there's a I kind of draw I draw a little
bit of an analogy over to like economic
terms like creative destruction
right and so what's interesting is you
have these times of great consolidation
and then you have these times of great
disruption right and those things get
reconciled so think of it as a pendulum
swinging and so the same thing is
happening in industries where people are
afraid of advanced technologies because
they say oh it's gonna take away jobs or
it's gonna it's gonna do this or it's
gonna do that and and maybe it does but
most often these new innovations which
are initially perceived as threats end
up creating more prosperity and more
access and more abilities than if we had
just stayed where we were so there's
Anestis where ethical as long as you're
skeptical and you you know to some
degree you you make sure that there's a
way of handling the change at a societal
level right so I mean we're not talking
about body hacking but you think about
you know self-driving I'm just been
thinking about this on the way up here
was like self-driving semi trucks right
and and what's gonna happen to all of
the people who are all over the road
truck drivers right and you know that's
a huge disruption right and it's coming
and but the how does that get throttled
so to speak in such a way that enables
the livelihood to continue or even
prosper for people that that's their
livelihood you know and you see that in
lots of different industries whether
it's accounting and taxes or you're
talking about health care and medical
stuff right is it the most
upstream issue our illusion of
separation is causing all of the
downstream issues the illusion of
separation or lack of interconnected
well I think the point that I was trying
to guess yes fondness was to bring me
back to those the for instance social
media right social media was to bring us
closer together but the paradox is that
you know so many ways has created more
isolation and and and it's a bit of an
interesting thing it's like is it
actually creating isolation is like
social media creating more isolated
people because there's now a screen
between us right
or is it actually just
herpes like you know everybody has
herpes but it takes something
environmental or some other trigger to
cause it to flare up so is every human
being just engineered to be super
depressive and super isolated in general
and many people have to work to be
social right there's a lot of introverts
I myself as one right there's a lot of
people who are introverted who have to
work very very hard to be social you
know and they want to feel connected but
they still they still sort of love and
cherish their independence and their
isolation you know so it's this
interesting sort of paradox but so is
the illusion of you know I think you
said is like is the illusion of us being
together or separated you know I think
it's it's it's not an illusion I think
it's the technology that we've created
has unintended consequences there that I
think that's the key around technology
in social engineering technology in
lifestyle design technology and
augmentation is being mindful of the
unintended consequences
and you may still proceed and say we're
going to embrace those unintended
consequences because there's lots of
stuff we don't know and if we don't
embrace it then we don't know what we're
dealing with so you have to push forward
in many ways but if you are absent
minded and you are just going into
something you may Rajas promise problems
it seems like the more upstream we go
with diving deep into our feelings of
interconnectedness our feelings of deep
amounts of unconditional love for each
other of present moment awareness with
each other the more that we are aware of
that those feelings on a
moment-to-moment basis the less likely
we are to have downstream issues of
ethical slips or moral slips or all
these potential issues but ok that was
that was that bit let's get on to this
yeah because this is a huge leap
downstream
here we are augmented humans right we're
talking about this everyone's wondering
you know if the purse right now who owns
the data this is a big one right now
another one who owns the substrate if
I'm literally gonna be entering these VR
environments and AR environments you
guys own the substrate so what so you
guys get to do whatever you want with
the environment that I enter into if it
becomes that popular which it totally
looks like people want to play gods in
these in these worlds where they can
manipulate bits instead of atoms you
know and okay so the question then as we
get into this augmented age of all of
our faculties of awareness is then you
know you guys at cognition are focusing
on a very very very ethically grounded
mission statement and this is personally
what I would love to see out of more
companies the companies are not starting
from that first principle this is what
when it when like the demo that you're
about to show this idea of the next OS
being first and foremost built for
people that are having issues with
speech and motor impairment that that
that are able to creatively flourish
because of technology that you make for
them and then those augmentations can
then be then apply to even more people
in unique ways that we don't in in like
you said senses that we don't even have
yet
hmm I'm loving this this is stuff I'm
loving all the creative potential being
released Unleashed hmm and that's
exactly what it is right it's it's I
think what the oneness I think that most
people share is is we all have a shared
desire right some people don't want to
be loved
some people do want to be loved some
people love is not the most important
thing right to be understood is more
fundamental than being loved
right so being understood not even
accepted but be understood right because
ultimately to be understood means that
there's integrity and you can build
integrity you can build on integrity
right so if I'm doing something and you
understand it correctly you can respond
to it all right
and whether that's you as a human
responding to me on a request level or
whether it's a robot responding to me or
whether it's you know software
responding to me it's about building a
foundation of integrity and making sure
that there's a like if you think about
you know I'm recognizing something I'm
classifying it correctly right I'm
speaking to you you're recognizing it
you're classifying it you're then
responding back to me
it's an actuator this is a closed-loop
like what we're doing is machine
learning over and over and over again
right and so that's all this is is we
are humans are meaning making machines
and essentially we're making inferences
and meaning of all of the [ __ ] that's
coming in and around me and we're
responding to that yes with our scenario
planning and zest judgments right and so
you think about just individual decision
making group decision making factoring
multiple inputs from a variety of
contextual yes data points and being
able to synthesize that into an action
in action right and so how do we
recreate that right how do we augment
someone if someone has a sensory deficit
yeah how do we restore or replace or you
know substitute that sensory deficit so
how can you have more context awareness
so that if I use an example where you
know somebody may not have situational
awareness you know so you might have say
a child with autism you might have a
teenager with autism and you're on the
playground at school and cognitively and
literacy levels they're off the charts
behaviorally they aren't able to key off
of any kind of prompts or clues so they
need a secondary prompt to inform them
that hey by the way response look at
look at look at your friends eyes
I'll make eye contact so some a child
might need to get a bit of a nudge or
they might engineer a prompt in order
for that in child to realize oh I need
to make eye contact with you while I'm
talking right that can be done with a
human as an aide or it could actually
you could replace the human is there an
alternative technological way to have a
contextually aware prompt that that
triggers me to make eye contact so that
I can then start to get that
reinforcement learning to say when I
interact with you I now need to make eye
contact does that need to be a human
that's paid tens of thousands of dollars
to to nudge me along or can that be
technology can I have more agency over
my life and my development as a human
being and can technology somehow help
shore that up so that I have that agency
and I'm not dependent on other humans to
feel one does not mean to feel dependent
to feel one means that you should have
as much agency as you can have and that
you feel as close to being on a level
playing field as those around you right
that you may not be able to do certain
things as good as the other person but
there's probably some things you can do
that's way better than the other person
right and the ability to be able to you
know have those kinds of relationships
that's a trust that is integrity and so
you really I see how you can create
social transformation cultural
transformation economic transformation
in the world by addressing the root
cause which is communication and
underneath communication is very simply
can we create a platform for being
understood interesting that that's where
you go with it I
I'm so interested in that first
principle of yours so communications
about being understood and so the
augmentation of communication augments
the amount of people that feel
understood and then by also as you go
into figuring out how to augment this
communication you have to do things like
figure out how to do something as
complex as having a when you have a
speech or motor impairment how do you
actually build something that is
extremely user experience friendly that
gets people to love the experience of
having one of their senses augmented and
then you can provide that as a beautiful
service to people yeah you know it's
it's well so I've been in design for
like 25 years
so my background is user experience
design so I kind of go way back and most
of my experience has been in natural
user interfaces so dealing with how do
you use technology in a way that maybe
wasn't meant or wasn't designed to do it
that way you know in in in how do you
create that user experience where
somebody has a viscerally positive
experience like right away there's
marketing terms called like time to
value T TV and so the whole goal of
developing a delightful user experience
where someone not only likes it they but
they fall in love with it and it becomes
a bit ritualistic is that you're
continually you can deliver the value
proposition as fast as possible so they
have that aha moment that you can meet
or exceed or deliver a part of the
experience in a way that they didn't
expect right surprise it's not just
delight but it's surprise and delight
and so for instance you know being able
to pick up a device and without having
to do anything you know Apple does this
really well they started out like with
the touch ID being able to unlock the
phone with your with your fingerprint
then now being able to unlock it with
your face you know with
sidee these are things that are
extremely delightful in the sense of wow
you just took away a whole bunch of
mechanical steps that I have to take and
you're now making it possible for the
technology to adapt to me and shortcut a
whole bunch of manual steps so that I'm
more productive I'm higher capacity I
feel more powerful as a human because I
can get to what I want to do you're
eliminating the time it takes for me to
have the values yes like so if I pick up
my smartphone and I am thinking oh I
need to go look at a PDF file in my
email right because somebody's calling
me about it right how long does it take
for me to get to that PDF file in my
phone like for my phone I have to pick
up the phone and you clock it in
milliseconds right it's like how long
does it take for me to cognitively think
okay I need to get that PDF I need to
look at it there's a specific phrase or
clause and that contract and that PDF
that they want me to look at yeah and
I'm like where am I gonna get it I'm you
know and so I have to mentally like it's
unstructured and we want to we want to
structure that data right but in your
mind you're you're actually to get to
the PDF you're actually getting the PDF
like a dozen times you're actually to
get to the PDF you're getting it like a
dozen times you are mentally you've
already cognitively gotten the PDF you
went looking for it in your mind what
are the steps it would I would need to
do to go get the PDF before you even
pick up the device then you pick up the
device and you're like oh I have to
enter these keys and all this stuff to
get in to get it unlock the phone then I
have to sweep and find the app and I
find the app and I have to go and look
in my inbox and I have to do a search
and I have to drill down and I have to
figure out like oh I'm looking for the
paperclip gosh this OS is so archaic and
then you go down to the operate and
you're like oh there's the is that the
right is that the right one oh that is
the right PDF okay launch it I preview
it I have to scroll it zoom pinch
zoom to get in and then now I have to
read it so your elapsed time on that
I've mentally gone through it's so heavy
right like the cognitive load to go get
a PDF out of your email like I'm not in
the email redesign business but that's
just an example right there's companies
that are trying to solve that problem
but the point of the matter is
technology now with things like the
ability to do face ID or touch ID has
just eliminated so much cognitive load
for me to get in and start accomplishing
the things I want to do right so those
types of technologies were designed for
security and authentication well we look
at that as is a great opportunity it's
like well can we use some of those same
technologies to provide a control
interface right can can we start to
observe your biometric data in such a
way to understand at 60 frames a second
what your emotional state is and those
miny micro shifts and emotional facial
recognition and you know expressive
qualities that could be semantically
analyzed can we understand you better
and your mental state and your emotional
state as it relates to how you're
accessing certain stuff and then can we
actually use the same onboard sensors to
allow you without using your hands at
all like I can just literally look at
the device and unlock it and I can go to
the apps and open the app and I can
start talking or start moving stuff
around and not lift a finger and and
some might say well that's you're
causing obesity problems if all of a
sudden you're letting people just sort
of sit on their asses on the sofa and
just have their iPad or something on the
you know on the coffee table and it's
like oh I'm just gonna do this stuff
remotely but how powerful is that that
now technology you know I don't have to
sit here and like pull out the keyboard
and type stuff in and use the mouse and
do all this stuff it's not about smart
people using dumb devices to enter data
into into systems anymore right it's
smart systems that are starting to adapt
and learn and respond to me and so we
sort of ice
this future where technology is going to
be much much more sensitive like if you
can design love and empathy as a part of
the underlying values and principles of
how your software operates right like
how do you actually human eyes the eye
right you can give it humanistic
qualities you can also give it a set of
values right you can so whether those
values depends on where those values
come from right but it has a lot to do
with your underlying philosophy of how
you're designing technology and you can
either design technology to make
machines smarter or you can design
technology to makes machines adapt and
support humans and I think that's the
philosophical frame that we think is
where things need to go and when we say
augmentation it's not just about
offloading loads and loads of data to
the cloud and processing stuff over 5g
it's really how can we make technology
as symbiotic to the human experience as
possible right where I don't have to
actually even look at a thing I don't
have to go look for my phone or look for
my iPad right I can access the data as
soon as I think it right that's where
it's going is like as soon as I think
about something I should be able to have
instant hands-free access to that data
yeah and then be able to take something
like whatever your unique blueprint is
that you have to bring some sort of a
gift to the world you can then take and
visualize this most concrete data around
that unique gift or blueprint they bring
to the world and then make actions on it
and then when you get the step by step
closer held things to also augmentation
technologies it makes it so that all the
things that we're building this future
why are we building it is actually going
towards a benevolent loving ethical
purpose so long as it steward it the
right way with so long as the right
leaders in technology and the right
ethicists and the right people or you
know things can get out of hand you know
so I think you need to have the
right yeah you have to have the right
philosophical perspective and how you're
embedding and designing you some of the
most important things that I've been
learning from you about people that have
speech and motor impairments are just
the stories that you've been telling me
about your ability to restore their
senses and augment their augment their
senses and bring them back to an ability
to communicate and creatively flourish I
love these stories so hit us with these
stories and then we'll talk about how
the tech works yeah so you know well
there's a couple stories of like folks
who didn't have our technology right and
you can see why they would need it and
so like one story that we learned about
was a this gentleman he had a cerebral
palsy and he was in a wheelchair so so
really fully immobilized in a wheelchair
and he was being transported ninety
miles to the next city
so this was in Santa Barbara he was
being shuttled up to Pismo Beach and
when they were loading him into the van
everything was normal like every time
they load him in and then as soon as
they started to get going everything
seemed normal
and then they arrived ninety minutes
later in Pismo they opened up the door
clash and then they they're like why is
why is this guy all sweaty and red and
just looking like he's about to die like
what's wrong with this guy and what
happened over the last 90 minutes and
they were trying to figure out what's
going on with this guy and then
literally like a while later they
realized that they had actually clipped
his belly with the seatbelt and he rode
90 minutes with his flesh pinched in a
seatbelt and he had no access to speech
like he couldn't say ouch
yeah he couldn't say hey guys like stop
you know so so imagine not being able to
speak when you have something like that
that's a it's an accident nobody meant
to do it yeah but you're like wow you
know imagine like the breakdowns of not
having communication you know but on the
upside you know we have other folks who
are using our technology like there's a
guy that we've learned about that he's a
DJ right he's a DJ he's in a motorized
wheelchair he is such an awesome
personality I mean an amazing amazing
human being and he DJ's he DJed for the
Special Olympics and in the LA I guess
the Colosseum and stuff and he's gigging
and doing all this kind of stuff he's
living his life charging hard and he he
he gets around he does this thing but so
one of the frustrations he had is like
when he's DJing and people come up and
they're like hey can you play whatever
song right or can you do this we could
do that and he's like dude I can't like
I can't talk to you so we hooked him up
with a mounting bracket and an iPad
running a speech application that we
made called speak prose and we're using
our embedded eye tracking and facial
recognition and he'd plugged that thing
up to a sound board and now he's DJing
partying and anytime he needs to talk to
somebody over his sound system he just
literally like looks over glances and
blinks and it says what he needs to say
he's essentially created a bionic third
arm that's a natural extension so you
might even call it in like a neural
prosthesis you might even call it just a
phantom limb it's a third appendage
right but it's an extra capability so on
one hand you have individuals who might
need stuff like this augmentation just
for basic core functional living life
right and dealing with the basic stuff
then you have the other situations where
people they can completely set their
creative direction for their life they
can totally set sail and go where they
want to go right and it's not just about
communication you know like what we're
doing is you know you know with like
things like AI assistants like Siri and
you know katana Alexa these things and
you know now you can control stuff right
so it's not just like hey I want to talk
to you it's hey I want to turn on the
lights hey I want to change the music
station hey I want to order some
pao chicken you know you know so now
through natural language understanding
and natural language systems right NLP
you know you building AI agents on the
backend we've created a user interface
that's core which is a communications
interface that not only allows people to
speak but they can also control their
world and their destiny right so imagine
like okay you're my full-time caregiver
and I'm gonna tell you what I want well
I could just do that myself like I don't
need to say like type out something on
my eye-tracking keyboard and say could
you turn the lights on I can just say
lights on right you know like I don't
need you to cut I don't need to say hey
Julie or whoever you know come come help
me out it's like change the station
right you know imagine being able to
turn on a Roomba like you know clean up
my mess and then your mess is attached
to a skill that tells your Roomba to
come out and vacuum up the popcorn on
the floor you know you now have all this
agency and you can do it hands-free with
your eyes in your face you know like
this is the future where you say wow
this is a transformation for lots and
lots of people right in a way that's
accessible today you know you think
about Stephen Hawking Stephen Hawking is
amazing you know so much creativity and
so much knowledge is sort of bottled up
inside of a vessel right like Stephen
Hawking's amazing but there's millions
of other people that are amazing too
that didn't have the resources that he
had you know so he had wonderful
partners you know Intel and others that
worked around with Stephen Hawking to
help provide his early technology you
know the universities and grants and
everybody rallied around Stephen but
here you have literally millions of
other people killed including children
and older people who have lots to say
and do like we have people that use our
technology now that are there artists
and we have individuals who literally
have a quarter of a million followers on
YouTube who want to become nonverbal
talk show
imagine like individuals with autism
that are going to become nonverbal
talk-show hosts you started to see I
think in the highest orders of
government in Japan they now have two
people with severe disabilities that are
holding court in Japan you know you're
starting to see a world that because of
these augmentations because of these
accessible technologies who knows what
kind of ideas are going to come from
these corners that have been otherwise
overlooked yes I want you to show us the
this new input/output mmm it's new OS
hmm let's do a demo yeah so most people
that are using this kind of technology
what we've created essentially we've got
an app that's running it's loaded onto
an iPad pro and we're analyzing your
face and your eyes so if you look at
these they're marked red because they're
not looking at my eyes yet mice my
connection is broken so it's a
biofeedback mechanism that allows for
forgiveness in the system right that I'm
not going to be stressed out and
frustrated if things aren't behaving the
way I want because it's giving me that
indication that oh something's out of
alignment so I can level stet and be not
so stressed out and you know but also if
I do this and I get closer the eyes get
bigger or further away so for me to get
this calibrated or not even calibrated
but just comfortably positioned I get
that biofeedback straightaway but
normally somebody that might have a
disability say with ALS or multiple
sclerosis or cerebral palsy or something
like that or a stroke or a traumatic
brain injury they might have this iPad
on a mount and the mount is actually got
a bracket that's connected to say a
wheelchair so that this is in a fixed
position so that they can access at any
time so essentially what I'm doing here
and I you can see that I didn't do any
calibration all I'm doing is just
holding it and instantly I can I can
access and I can say thanks right I can
acts I can talk to you right I can
I can say yes I can ask you questions
like I don't know what's your name so I
can come up in here and say like oh look
what's your name
alright I can start to have
conversations I can start to have
conversations in an augmentative way if
I wanted to do something like go outside
I might say oh I want to go oh I want to
go outside just I try this yeah this is
my eyes I'm not touching anything I want
to go outside now and I want to be
really nice about it so I'm gonna say
please or now I'm actually gonna say I
want to go outside now with you right so
now I can come in here and start to have
a conversation to go outside with you
so if that's that's like structured
functional communication but if I wanted
to kind of go totally unstructured right
I
we've got integrated keyboards right so
I could be like oh man
I can actually drive this whole thing
with my face
right I'm just literally just like wow
that's really awesome
keyboards hard but it still works
really awesome right so the ability to
access this right so the next best
alternative for something like this
you're talking about twenty or thirty
thousand dollars for solutions that are
in the market today
versus what we're doing we make the
software available if you've already got
the iPad you can DIY it and you can get
it yourself if you're technically savvy
a lot of people like to rely on
insurance to pay for these kinds of
solutions so we just got approved this
November to start providing this as a
solution through insurance so you know
now more and more people are going to be
able to access these kinds of
capabilities so this is just the
beginning of what's possible right for
augmenting someone's abilities you're
asking earlier right about user
experience and how to you know how to
how to get to time to value for the end
user but the interesting thing is when
you're developing things like Bionic
augmentations like this might be
considered a bionic augmentation right
for someone with a disability you're not
only designing it for them right
you're augmenting their capacity their
capabilities but you also have to design
it for their loved ones right or
whomever is around them so you have a
full 360 that you've got to really take
into consideration and usually what
we've learned is anytime you're doing
augmentative technologies if the person
who is the primary care giver or the
person who spends the most time with the
individual if they don't understand how
to use it and they don't know how to
admin it they're not tech savvy and most
people aren't if it's not designed to be
really really simple right out of the
box it's not going to get used so like
millions and millions of dollars are
being spent on assistive technologies
today that end up going in the drawer
not because the end user doesn't need it
or can't use it it's because the person
that they rely on it's too complicated
it's too complicated so it's really
really critical for anyone anyone in the
industry developing technology they need
to be very sensitive to spending time
too
really try and simplify things as much
as they can understanding that everybody
isn't just like you right like you might
tolerate complex user interfaces most
people can't most people don't and if
your goal if your value proposition is
to create a lasting effect for
augmenting someone's abilities that
means that they're gonna basically be
relying on the technology every single
day right and if they're gonna rely on
it every single day then it needs to be
really easy for them to learn right and
that's where software like AI comes in
right it's like well there's a certain
amount of a learning curve that comes
from the user but then there's a certain
amount that comes from the system so if
you think about like I don't play the
piano but man if I could kind of start
to learn to play the piano and then the
piano started to learn me and met me in
the middle I wonder what kind of music I
could play right any all kinds of Bionic
systems are just like learning to play a
musical instrument yeah you're
developing a new skill you're learning
to do new things with your body in
different ways whether that's physically
or with your mind
and so the ability to mentally control
stuff right either with your eyes your
face or even directly with your brain as
a brain interface right these are new
skills that we need to learn but we also
need to have the technology learn us so
that it makes the learning curve faster
and easier right that someone feels like
just the way I demonstrated that I just
literally picked up the iPad and I just
started using it yes I didn't have to
read a menu it just learned me yes and
it just started doing what I needed it
to do yeah that's how you develop a
Bionic capability
[Music]